[Música]
quiero escribir
es una pregunta que me hacen con cierta
frecuencia por esto de que mucha gente
sabe que escribo y es un deseo que
muchos tenemos el de escribir el de
largarnos a escribir y el de tener una
noción de por dónde empezar
y mi respuesta habitualmente es cuando
me preguntan cómo hago no sé
tiene mala prensa responder no sé
pero tiene una razón cualquier actividad
artística tiene una cosa medio
inaprensible medio difícil de agarrar
entonces es complicado dar consejos
porque aparte no hay una sola manera uno
conoce la propia nada más no conoce
otras posibles y hasta te da medio miedo
de decir de un modo y alomejor esa
persona necesita que sea otro el modo
con lo cual podría terminar acá mi
charla ted
pero en general cuando alguien se me
acerque me dice quiero escribir a mí más
que algunas respuestas se me ocurren
algunas preguntas para formularle la
persona que quiere escribir
y una primera pregunta clave es leer
ya sé que vos querés escribir
pero lees
para damos una base estamos hablando de
si vos querés escribir para llegar a
otros porque si tu idea es escribir y
sacar cosas que tenés adentro y
suficiente para vos con eso
es suficiente
ahora bien si vos querés que lo que vos
escribas le llegue de algún modo de los
demás que leas es clave porque
porque no hay otra manera en el fondo de
aprender a escribir que no sea leyendo
se nutre de palabras y te nutre de
ritmos escribir contar historias tiene
un tempo hay música en el contar
es imperceptible si está bien encontrado
bueno lo ves si está mal contados y lo
es porque se traba porque se afloja
porque te aburre porque te confunde
pero para que no se note todo eso
uno leyendo es un modo de ir tomando ese
tiempo de las cosas se te afina el oído
leyendo leyendo de todo no es que tenga
que leer clásicos universales y puntos
leyendo lo que te guste leyendo lo que
te apasione porque si te apasiona leer
llegas al momento de escribir queriendo
meter ahí vos tu granito de arena en eso
que está escrito y no te vas a copiar de
lo que leíste no te va a pasar eso pero
lo que leíste es un guiso enorme que
está en tu cabeza y en el que meter la
cuchara para escribir vos que hay en ese
guiso todo lo que leíste desde en mi
caso patoruzito a cortázar y está todo
adentro
una segunda pregunta que es súper
importante
ponerle que estás escribiendo estás
largando te describir
corregir
corregir lo que escribís
si me decís que no
y estamos complicados
cuando uno escribe el momento de
escribir es un momento pasional es un
momento íntimo emotivo profundo fecundo
muy caótico muy anárquico y tiene que
ser así vos cuando estás escribiendo
estás metiéndote en el medio de vos
y no tienes tiempo de vigilar las comas
o no tienes tiempo de revisar
redundancias y mejorar adjetivaciones
cuando vos escribís muchas veces
terminas de escribir y te sentís
porque necesitaba sacarte eso de encima
pero hiciste eso pero sacaste de encima
después tenéis que volverlo a traer y
revisarlo como un artesano
como no como un artista sino como un
artesano en lo pequeño en la palabra en
el detalle y eso es aburrido tedioso
sacrificado denso es todo eso corregir
pero tengan algo en cuenta porque es tan
importante que vos corrijas porque
cuando uno escribe está emocionado está
conmocionado con lo que está escribiendo
pero nuestro lector no
en el mejor de los casos nuestro lector
termina emocionado pero no empiece a
emocionado y lo mismo vale por una
película podemos presentarse a ver una
película no estás copadi ximo ojalá
termine es comodísimo pero ese péndulo
que tiene que ir desde vos conmovido a
tu lector conmovido
en el medio lo que hay es una buena obra
de ingeniería
no es que vos dibujas planos cuando
escribís pero en algún momento eso que
escribís necesita planos necesita los
adjetivos puesto de un modo los tiempos
verbales el nivel de registro
los diálogos hechos de determinada
manera y eso es aburrido pero necesario
y hay otra pregunta que es súper
importante y la más importante de todas
que es
para quien escribir
es súper legitima cualquier respuesta
y en cualquier persona que tenga deseos
de convertirse en escritor la respuesta
para nosotros es recontra legítima mucho
de lo que hacemos lo hacemos para los
demás y está bien si alguien me dice yo
quiero ser escritor porque quiero que me
lean
está muy bien que así sea
ahora
ojo con esa respuesta en particular
porque
su ponente por uno puede decir quiero
escribir para que los otros me lean y me
lean masivamente y convertirme en una
escritora tiempo completo y vivir de
esto el legítimo se deseo si es fácil no
es difícil no es mucho peor que difícil
y está bueno que lo sepas porque a lo
mejor mozo bueno haciendo eso pero que
seas bueno no significa que puedas vivir
de esto
entonces una idea es no vincule es el
hecho de sentirte escritor de sentirte
escritora con que pueda vivir de esto
capaz que no pasa y no está mal que vote
sientas escritora igual
y quiero publicar libros también no voy
a vivir de ser escrito viviré de otra
cosa pero quiero publicar libros el
legítimo es recontra legítimo pero
también es difícil
es difícil que enganches una editorial
que le interese y qué
es difícil
para mí la respuesta más genuina
es que escribes para vos
que germinan porque la que me pasa a mí
y no sé si es la mejor
pero no un para vos que ahí no me
interesa lo que piensa en los demás
siempre nos interesa lo que piensen los
demás
y siempre nos interesa
y los demás nos acepten
y que nos valoren
pero no escribas esperando eso porque si
no vas a perder la libertad de lo que
tenés que hablar porque si vos estás
escribiendo imaginando la cara de tu
eventual lector o la reacción de tu
eventual lector
vas a dejar de decir lo que necesitas
en el fondo lo más importante es que
hables de lo que necesitas hablar a mí
al menos me pasa así
saben que fue lo primero que yo escribí
hace 25 años no fue un cuento
no fue una novela
no fue un guión de cine
una carta
está un poquito oxidado el ganchito
impresora
epson de punto hay gente la mitad del
auditorio no sabe de qué estoy hablando
y una carta de mi papá
yo en esa época no podía dormir
y necesite escribir esa carta
y lo que me di cuenta
es que escribir a mí me permite dormir
yo escribo para dormir
escribo para estar lo suficientemente
sereno con el mundo como para dormir
y a lo largo de mi vida cada cosa que he
escrito aunque yo en el momento que la
estoy escribiendo no me dé cuenta lo que
hace es permitirme dormir les doy un
ejemplo
cuando yo estaba en la facultad
estudiando historia trabajaba en
tribunales en un juzgado criminal de
capital federal trabajo interesantísimo
era
estaba día a día con en contacto con
cosas muy densas y muy fuertes
delitos víctimas
detenidos abogados jueces fiscales
testigos
y un trabajo súper interesante donde
aprendí es un montón de cosas que haría
cualquier persona normal conservar ese
trabajo
yo vi en mi futuro
una gran chance de progreso me fui en el
año 91 a trabajar
a un videoclub
si necesitan asesoramiento para negocios
en el futuro
y saben que nunca me lo perdone
saben la de noches que yo soñaba que
volvía a trabajar a tribunales
la decepción que yo sentía cuando me
despertaba
y no había vuelto a trabajar a
tribunales
por suerte
se me ocurrió en medio de mi carrera
de escritor
inventar una historia que estaba
ambientada en mi mundo era mío ese mundo
entonces y poblar lo de gente que
trabajaba en tribunales y le gustaba y
trataba hacerlo bien
y así fue como nació
la pregunta de sus ojos esa novela
para que nació para que yo durmiera
a veces no pasa más nada con lo que uno
escribe
a veces si pasan cosas y puede pasar que
de la pregunta de sus ojos terminemos el
secreto de sus ojos
y el oscar y toda la milonga y que sigan
pasando cosas y la agarran los gringo la
película the secret in your eyes
pero
pero no no pero
el asunto es
dormir
mejor dicho acomodar tu vida
que tu vida sea un poco mejor que si no
escribiera
en medio de toda esa locura de el oscar
los medios sacar un pasaporte viajar a
hollywood
empezará una planta
yo antes era un profesor de historia con
un montón de horas de clase y de repente
que los medios que los viajes
y yo empezaba a sentirme como si hubiera
un viento que me movía
y un viento feliz sí pero me estaba
moviendo un lugar que a mí me gustaba
capas que se hubiera pensado en nosotros
al momento de escribir lo que seguía
tendría que haber hecho la pregunta de
sus ojos dos para hacer el secreto de
sus ojos 2
pero como yo necesitaba tirar el ancla
en mi vida
mi mente una historia de cuatro tipos
que son de castelar que mi pueblo que
son hincha de independiente como soy yo
que uno profesor no tiene un lavadero de
autos uno es abogado y uno compra un
jugador de fútbol
y así fue como nació mi siguiente novela
papeles en el viento china que ver con
el secreto de sus ojos
para que le escribí
para seguir durmiendo
y de policía un peligro igual
pero hablando en serio no importa
con cada historia
qué pasa
qué tiene que ver con vos
yo escribí un montón de cuentos de
fútbol y en esos cuentos del fútbol me
encuentro mucho con mi hijo mi hijo
varón
y en algún momento me di cuenta que no
tenía un libro con mi hija
y a mí me encanta la relación que tengo
conmigo
entonces me puse a escribir una historia
que fuera de un padre y una hija después
de hacer esa de papeles en el viento el
fútbol y yo que sé que el vídeo bárbaro
y película y yo que sé
y es una novela de un papá y una hija
conociéndose para que la escribí para
que mi hija dentro de 40 años diga a que
charlábamos con mi papá
cuando yo digo esto de dormir
de lo que estoy hablando es
hacemos arte
porque sabemos que la vida es tristísima
y durísima y dificilísimo
y eso es lo que no nos deja dormir
señor en las charlas ted
una última idea
[Aplausos]
yo soy el jovencito
pero advertirán que el problema capilar
no nació conmigo
si quieren escribir háganlo y usen lo
suelto para comunicarse con sus muertos
en el mejor de los sentidos gracias
[Aplausos]